Chipotle's menu only has a few items but
it's highly customizable born in 1993
that's what's made Chipotle one of the
most successful fast casual restaurant
chains in the U.S but in recent years
Chipotles faced many challenges between
2015 to 2018 Chipotle dealt with five
foodborne illness outbreaks like most of
the restaurant industry Chipotle's
Revenue took a big hit during the
beginning of the coronavirus pandemic
and today it's dealing with inflation
that's increased labor transportation
and food costs yet despite these
setbacks Chipotle sales are actually
growing here's how Chipotle's focus on
efficiency and Innovation helped it
bounce back and become one of the
country's most valuable Quick Service
chains this is the economics of Chipotle
Chipotle's Revenue has increased by more
than 200 percent over the past decade
its stock price has increased about 400
percent in the last five years much of
Chipotle's success comes from its
efficient and what it calls transparent
in-store experience Chipotle is really
in a lot of ways made the whole fast
casual category for restaurants it's not
fast food it's not full service they've
generated a lot of sales from people who
want this alternative that seems fresher
and faster than fast food but is not a
full service experience fast casual
design can help them reduce some of
their labor expenses which helps with
profits
Chipotle's menu is relatively small but
it's easy to customize there's tons of
stuff you can put on your meal that's
proteins that's cheeses that's
vegetables that's all the salsas and
sauces and for a customer that makes it
exciting you know they get lots of
different things they can customize
their meal with the more limited menu in
general is better for restaurants and
their profits it's less things to train
the restaurant workers on it's less
waste Chipotle's founder Steve Ells
emphasized having an open kitchen he
wanted customers to be able to see the
ingredients and preparation in front of
them
today employees work at individual
stations to serve already prepared
ingredients making the ordering process
more efficient for customers we can
serve as many as 100 customers within a
15-minute period what's a better way
than telling people that it's fresh
showing them let them come in and
discover for themselves this
transparency has been very important for
Chipotle especially after its food
safety issues after several outbreaks of
E coli salmonella and norovirus in
Chipotle restaurants the company
implemented several changes like
improving food preparation and storage
procedures encouraging sick employees to
stay at home and bringing on a new CEO
Brian Nichol he really did emphasize
that they had cleaned up their
procedures didn't happen immediately but
with time people start to forget things
too there hasn't been the big high
profile scares that there were
previously after several outbreaks
between 2015 and 2018 Chipotle's stock
price took a hit however its focus on
its digital ordering platforms helped
Drive up revenue and stock prices
started to climb back in 2008 Chipotle
became one of the first fast casual
chains to create an online store pickup
model in its first year Chipotle's
digital sales accounted for 13 million
dollars or just one percent of its total
sales in 2022 digital sales grew to 3.4
billion dollars that's now nearly 40
percent of Chipotle's food and beverage
Revenue if you're ordering online
digitally that is made for you at a
whole separate part of the kitchen which
is just dedicated to online orders
Chipotle's app and online ordering
systems were also vital during the
pandemic the pandemic obviously was
terrible for all restaurants but
Chipotle did have some advantages there
in that they had this whole digital
ordering platform really set up and
scaled
beforehand when the pandemic first hit
we saw that people stopped going to
restaurants for some period of time so
we saw our sales drop pretty
significantly but it only took like a
week or two before we started to see
that while they first stopped visiting
restaurants the adoption of the digital
ordering really picked up very very
quickly and so I would say within the
first four weeks we had our digital uh
ordering soared from about 18 to it at
one point hit 70 percent Chipotle also
designed its stores to have two separate
prep stations called make lines one make
line is just for in-store orders and the
other is for digital and Catering orders
this made food pickups quicker for
customers who didn't want to spend time
indoors this idea that we had the
digital make line so that as people were
ordering we could make food on a digital
make line and also serve customers that
were choosing to come in so it was a
seamless experience like most stocks
during 2020 they were still lower than
they were before the pandemic but by the
end of the first year into the second
year most stocks had you know fully
recovered we had our all-time high in
2021. recently Chipotle has continued to
expand its digital ordering services
with a new pickup option for customers
called chipotleans let's go ahead and
take offer all the convenience of the
drive-through but when you order ahead
of time you know exactly what time to
come and so there's no line you drive up
and you pull to our window you get your
food and off you go the first Chipotle
opened in 2018 and there are already
nearly 600 across the U.S Chipotle says
at least 80 percent of new restaurant
locations opening in 2023 will have
chipotleans but that's just one example
of how Chipotle has continued to
innovate to attract customers social
media has been great for us because in
addition to making sure we're serving
you know the meals that that customers
come to expect at Chipotle we also want
to be part of culture Chipotle
frequently uses social media to attract
younger consumers by releasing recipe
videos animated short films Roblox games
and social media campaigns like the lid
flip challenge with major influencers
Chipotle has also used social media to
drum up excitement about new menu items
and innovate its menu options to keep up
with consumer Trends adding new things
for customers is very important to
Chipotle and they have a whole process
for this where they try and try these
items in-house and really test and learn
before they test in stores they like
menu news whether it's
you know a steak item or a chicken item
al pastor
quesadillas they want to keep customers
interested even if most of their menu is
staying the same so what's next for
Chipotle in general the online ordering
even when you pick it up in the
restaurant is just much more efficient
the company says it wants to open more
locations that are only used for online
pickup orders they won't have any
seating for customers this will also cut
down on labor costs since workers won't
need to clean seating areas and
bathrooms as often we think the idea is
let the customers choose which channel
they want now our job is to make sure
every channel is convenient it's easy
it's fast so that we don't give any
friction whatsoever but make sure every
experience that you can provide on every
channel is a great one
foreign
[Music]